here's a holiday film that's gonna wreck
the Thanksgiving box-office I'm talking
about a drought breaks the internet and
we were with the all-star cast at their
big Hollywood premiere I picked this
dress today and I'm wearing army boots
under a very comfortable
comfy boots in a ball gown the newest
Disney Princess is kind of a
rule-breaker and we love it
in fact Ralph breaks the internet
brought all the past Disney Princesses
together to hang out with Sarah
Silverman's vanellope character it's
like honestly one of the greatest joys
of my life having played Rapunzel we
took the idea of the princesses and who
you think they are and allow them to
sort of like reveal their true selves I
guess this animated sequel has Ralph and
vanellope traveling to the Internet to
save her gaily from ruin it's where they
meet taraji Pete Henson who joins the
cast well wreck-it Ralph
you are trending and these are for you I
can't believe that I'm a part of the
Disney animated feature film family but
I'm here the next step is to give me a
song so that I can be a princess we're
all for that but we know john c reilly
isn't looking to be a prince he's just
happy being a dad I've got a great dad
joke what is a pirate's favorite letter
take a guess
I do love our but the C is me first love
pretty good right not a bad dad joke
[Music]